our societies have advanced tendencies
to label
some people winners and others logically
enough
losers aside from the evident meanness
of this categorization
the underlying problem with it is the
suggestion that life
is actually one race at the conclusion
to which
one can neatly rank all the competitors
from highest
to lowest but is it the more confusing
and complex truth
is that life is actually made up of a
number of races
that unfold simultaneously over quite
different
territory and with different sorts of
cups and medals in view
there are races for money fame and
prestige
of course and these attract many
spectators and
in some social circles the bulk of the
coverage
but there are also races that measure
other kinds of
prowess that it's worth venerating
there's a race
for who can remain calmest in the face
of frustration
there is a race for who can be kindest
to children
there is a race measuring how gifted
someone is at friendship
there are races focused on how attentive
someone is to the evening sky
or how good they are at deriving
pleasure from autumn fruits
despite our enthusiasm for trying to
sort out competitors into neat ranks
a striking fact about the multi-race
event of life
is quite simply that no one is ever able
to end up a winner
in every jar of competition available
furthermore prowess in one kind of race
seems to militate against one's chances
of success
in others winning at being ruthlessly
successful in business
seems not for example generally to go
hand in hand with any real ability
at the race to appreciate the sky or
find pleasure in figs
those who are terrific at gaining fame
tend to be hampered when it comes to
competing in the race
that measures the ability to be patient
around three-year-old children
we cannot it seems be winners at
everything those who appear to be
carrying off all the prizes
and are lauded in certain quarters as
superhuman athletes of life
cannot on closer examination really be
triumphing across the board
in any such way they are bound to be
making a deep mess
of some of the less familiar or
prestigious races that they had entered
for
in certain corners of the stadium they
might be falling over tripping up
complaining loudly about track
conditions
and perhaps sourly denigrating the whole
event as useless and
not worth participating in if one cannot
be a winner at everything
it follows that one cannot be a loser at
everything
either when we have failed in certain
races
in the miliathlon of life we retain
ample opportunities to train and develop
our strength
to win in others we may never again be
able to compete in the race for
fame honor or money but it's still
entirely open to us to compete in the
race for
kindness friendship and forgiveness we
may even win
at the not insignificant race for
enjoying one's own company
or sleeping very soundly and without
anxiety for many
hours we never starkly fail at life
itself when we mess up in worldly areas
and feel dejected and isolated
the universe is just giving us an
exceptional chance
to begin the training which means we
will one day
become star athletes in other less
well-known
but hugely important races races around
keeping a sense of humor showing
gratitude forgiving
appreciating letting go and making do
these are the noble tracks on which
those who feel
they have failed can finally properly
and redemptively learn to win
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected
areas of life click now to learn more
you